>> Will Sentance: Mọi người đều thích.
Tôi có một sự làm rõ.
Tôi ngạc nhiên rõ ràng, bạn đã mất tôi.
Được rồi, Victor có một sự làm rõ, Brian có một, Paul có một,
Michelle có một cái, Mike.
Mike tại sao bạn không đá chúng tôi, James có một, Mike tại sao bạn không đá chúng tôi?
>> Mike: Tôi chỉ đang thắc mắc hàng đợi gọi lại ở đâu,
là bạn sẽ lưu trữ nó trong một tính năng của trình duyệt web?
>> Will Sentance: Đó là một tính năng JavaScript.
Không, đó là một tính năng của công cụ JavaScript.
Câu hỏi rất, rất hay.
Đó là một tính năng của công cụ JavaScript.
Brian?
>> Brian: Được rồi, nó ưu tiên những thứ đó như thế nào?
Giống như nếu bạn có nhiều hơn những người trong thời gian đó.
Tất cả đều tăng từ 0 đến 10 hoặc tương tự như vậy.
Làm thế nào nó sẽ- >> Will Sentance: Vì vậy,
ngay sau khi họ hoàn thành, họ đi lên đây.
Nếu họ hoàn thành cùng một lúc, eh.
>> Will Sentance: Nó quá tinh vi, tôi không biết.
Tôi nghĩ đồng thời, kịch bản là không thể xảy ra, Alec?
>> Alec: Đó có phải là một ngăn xếp không?
Hàng đợi gọi lại?
>> Will Sentance: Có một hàng đợi.
>> Alec: Được rồi, nhưng.
>> Will Sentance: Đó là một hàng đợi theo nghĩa mà chúng ta đưa vào, in lời chào.
Nếu chúng tôi hoàn thành một tính năng trình duyệt web khác, và
tính năng trình duyệt web của nó có thể được vượt qua chức năng của nó.
Nó sẽ được xếp hàng phía sau, để bắt đầu tiếp theo.
Được rồi, vì vậy đó là lần đầu tiên xuất hiện trước.
Vì vậy, nó là một cấu trúc hàng đợi.
>> Will Sentance: [LAUGH] Không cười khúc khích trịch thượng,
Alec đã hỏi một câu hỏi rất chính đáng, liệu hàng đợi từ có phải là ngăn xếp không.
Một câu hỏi rất chính đáng.
Được rồi, ai khác đã có, Victor là người tiếp theo.
>> Người thuyết trình 5: Khoảng thời gian đặt có tác dụng gì?
>> Will Sentance: Hãy chờ đợi, Sandra, chúng ta sẽ làm điều đó, vâng,
đó là một điều rất thú vị.
Nhưng hãy nghĩ về nó giống như làm một cái gì đó rất giống trong trình duyệt web.
Tôi sẽ đến đó một đối một với bạn, anh bạn.
Có James khác?
>> Người nói 5: Vâng, tôi không thể nhớ, hàng đợi nhiệm vụ có nhận được không
được xử lý ở cuối vòng lặp sự kiện, hoặc ở đầu, hoặc xin lỗi,
sự lặp lại vòng lặp sự kiện, hay sự bắt đầu của lần lặp tiếp theo?
>> Will Sentance: Khi bạn đã hoàn thành tất cả các tác vụ đồng bộ.
>> Người phát biểu 5: Vậy là đã kết thúc lời phát biểu.
>> Will Sentance: Theo nghĩa đó, có.
Hãy đảm bảo rằng chúng tôi có bất kỳ câu hỏi trực tuyến nào mà chúng tôi đang trả lời.
Paul, tiếp tục đi.
>> Người nói 6: Tôi nghĩ rằng tôi có một câu hỏi, tôi chỉ muốn đảm bảo rằng tôi biết
phương pháp đặt thời gian chờ được cung cấp bởi môi trường trình duyệt.
>> Will Sentance: Yeah, yeah. Đặt thời gian, làm ơn đi trước, tiến lên.
>> Người thuyết trình 6: Vậy thì vòng lặp sự kiện và hàng đợi gọi lại không phải là duy nhất cho mỗi
thời gian chạy trình duyệt riêng lẻ nhưng nói không phải trình duyệt khác
thời gian chạy vv cũng sẽ có những- >> Will Sentance: Hoàn toàn,
cách Node triển khai các phần này tùy thuộc vào chúng, vì vậy
chúng ta sẽ đến phần sau về nơi nút được triển khai theo một cách hơi khác.
Nhưng chúng ta sẽ thấy điều đó một chút sau, anh bạn.
Nhưng đó là một câu hỏi hay, tuyệt vời.
Vâng, Ben?
>> Ben: Có giới hạn nào đối với kích thước này của hàng đợi gọi lại không?
>> Will Sentance: Ý tôi là, tôi cho là vậy nhưng đó là một câu hỏi thực sự hay.
Tôi sẽ nói rằng hãy kiểm tra nó và chúng ta sẽ nói về
bởi vì tất nhiên có một ngăn xếp cuộc gọi, hàng đợi gọi lại.
Ý tôi là miễn là đừng quên hàng đợi gọi lại,
bạn không lưu chức năng này ở đây.
Bạn đang tham khảo vị trí của nó trong bộ nhớ JavaScript, vì vậy câu hỏi là
thực sự, có giới hạn bộ nhớ JavaScript cho các định nghĩa hàm không?
Bạn có thấy?
Bạn không bị giới hạn, bạn không sao chép chức năng này ở đây, vì vậy
với tôi, câu hỏi là, có giới hạn bộ nhớ thời gian chạy Java Script không?
Vâng, có, nhưng điều đó ngụ ý cho hàng đợi gọi lại của bạn, bất kể giới hạn đó là gì,
cái nào độc lập với hàng đợi gọi lại, điều đó có hợp lý không Ben?
>> Ben: Vâng.
>> Will Sentance: Câu hỏi hay.
Có Michelle? >> Michelle: Tôi chỉ tự hỏi liệu
vòng lặp sự kiện cũng là một phần của công cụ JavaScript mà bạn đã tham chiếu?
>> Will Sentance: Mhmm, hoàn toàn, nhưng nó sẽ còn nhiều thứ hơn nữa
hơn là chỉ xử lý điều này, nhưng chúng ta sẽ thấy những điều đó trong giây lát.
Sean. >> Sean: Điều gì sẽ xảy ra khi bạn đi vào
một chức năng ẩn danh đến thời gian đặt ra?
>> Will Sentance: Chức năng ẩn danh,
bạn hầu như có thể nghĩ chúng được lưu trữ trong bộ nhớ giống như các hàm không được gắn nhãn.
Nhưng họ vẫn có một vị trí và địa chỉ trong trí nhớ.
Hãy nghĩ rằng chúng ta không thực sự chuyển nhãn cho hàm.
Dưới mui xe, những gì chúng tôi đang truyền tải là một tham chiếu hoặc
vị trí cụ thể trong bộ nhớ.
Và vì vậy, nếu chúng ta không có nhãn để in hello, chúng ta truyền một hàm gián tiếp.
Chức năng đó vẫn đang được xác định trong bộ nhớ chung.
Khi tôi chạy, hãy đặt thời gian chờ và tạm dừng để hoạt động, không phải là chức năng được gắn nhãn.
Nhưng khi tôi xác định ngay trong dấu ngoặc đơn,
vẫn đang được lưu trữ trong bộ nhớ chung mà không có nhãn.
Và đó là hàm được tham chiếu cuối cùng được tham chiếu ở đây.
Điều này hiện không có nhãn, nhưng nó vẫn tham chiếu đến vị trí trong
Bộ nhớ chung của Java Script, nơi hàm đó được định nghĩa.
Có ý nghĩa? Đúng.
>> Mike: Câu hỏi hay.